شجاعه مثبرا بازلت انا من التوفيليس مؤسسه
مركز بلوم لتاهيل الاطفال ذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه
[موسيقى]
اللي كانت في حياتي فيها نقطه التحول كانت
اليوم اللي انا قررت فيه امشي من بيت اهلي
واستقل واعيش لوحدي دي مش حاجه متداوله
قوي في مصر بالذات لو انت مش متجوزه واهلك
مش عايشين في محافظه ثانيه ومش بتشتغلي في
محافظه ثانيه بس انا عمري ما هنسى اليوم
ده انا فاكره كويس قوي ان انا قعدت في
اوضتي بالليل وقعدت للصبح صاحيه بافكر انا
واقفه فين في حياتي انا بعمل ايه في حياتي
وفي الوقت ده كنت بعدي في وقت صعب قوي ودي
ممكن
[موسيقى]
تربيه كلها عن المسؤوليه
في الوقت ده ابتدات ادخل على فيسبوك وادور
على ناس بتشتغل في نفس مجال شغلي بس
بيعملوا ايه او بيشتغلوا فين
وفيك تتعرف على ناس وابتدا يجي لي شغل من
غير
تدور كثير يجي لي حاجات اعملها فاشتغلت
ثلاث شغلانات وبعد اول شهر بالضبط الاهلي
دفعوا اجاره كنت استقلت ماديا الكمبيوتر
يعني اهلي
ما كنتش محظوظه قوي عشان بعدها يمكن سته
او سبعه شهور جات كورونا وكل حاجه وقفت
المصدر داخلي وقعدت في البيت مش عارفه
اسيب البيت وارجع عند اهلي ثاني ولا اشوف
هاعمل ايه وفي الوقت ده ابتديت اقعد مع
نفسي انت انت عايزه تعملي ايه انت انت ليه
بتعملي كل ده مفترسه افكر في الاحلام اللي
كانت عندي اللي هي كانت مجرد احلام بفكر
فيها اه انا عايزه يبقى انا عايزه يبقى
عندي شغل مهمه للمجتمع عمري ما كان عندي
خطه ما انا باعوز بس ما باعملش خطط وقعدت
تغليت الوقت اللي قعدته في البيت ده انه
اشوف انا ايه انا هاعمل ايه واول ما
ابتدات الحياه تفتح ثاني رحت الاهلي قلت
لهم انا انا عايزه اعمل طب معك فلوس معك
ولا مليم انا طبعا انا معيش اي انا هاعمل
السبت ده مين هيشتغل فيه هنعمل ايه ارنوب
وابتدينا ندور على اماكن وهم برده اجن
ساعدوني لاحسسهم برده ان دي حاجه مجنونه
زي المره اللي فاتت وبعدين هنلف في الخطه
وعادي ولقينا مكانه مكان ده كان اكبر قوي
من ما انا محتاجه واكبر قوي من الفلوس
اصلا اللي انا بادخلها برده في الشهر بس
هم اتحمسوا للفكره يعني اقرا اوكي هنجرب
ممكن يبان شيليها سيب البيت واسكن في نفس
المكان يعني هنشوف واخذت المكان وابتدى
يجيء لي بتتكلم للناس اللي كانوا بيتعلموا
عندي قبل الكرونه عندنا اخذت مكانه وتعال
وكده وابتدا يجي له ناس شويه همم قليلين
بس ابتدا يجي شويه ناس وبعدين قررت ثاني
اعمل فكره مجنونه وابدا اعمل انترنت اجيب
طلب الجامعه في المكان الفاضي اللي ما
فيهوش غير اربع عيال اللي هو بيشتغل مثلا
خمس ست ساعات في الاسبوع وابتديت اجيبهم
وادربهم وكده وفي خلال يمكن اقل من ثلاث
شهور كناف بكره كان في مواعيد طول الوقت
كنت اشتغل الصبح بالليل ابتدى يجيء ناس
معايا وكانت ناس تكلمني انا عايزه اشتغل
معك بيجيئوا يشتغلوا احنا بقى لنا دلوقت
يمكن سنتين وارفلى بوك طول الوقت طول
السنه
انا كبرت في عيله معظمها ستات يعني كانوا
البابايا هو كان الميل فجر الوحيد والباقي
كله اللي كانوا حواليا عمتي خالتي جدتي
مامتي
[موسيقى]
ومعظم الستات اللي في عيلتي حياتهم كلها
نفس اللي عرفتك اللي هم سابه الكبير
بتاعهم عشان البيت والاولاد وكده وكنت
دائما ببص على الحاجه دي باحترام شديد جدا
بس حاسه ان انا انا مش زيهم او انا مش
هاعرف اعيش الحياه دي وحتى لما كبرت كانوا
اهلي دائما
يعني انا دلوقت عندي احلام كثير قوي بس
اكثر حاجه انا نفسي فيها همم
هي انه اقدر اعمل في مصر مكان للتاهيل
الاطفال اللي عندها احتياجات خاصه يكون
شبه الحاجات اللي بتحصل لبره في امريكا
واوروبا اللي نسبه سافر لها فنفسي يبقى
المكان مش بس بيساعد الاولاد لكن بيساعد
اهاليهم وبيقدم خدمه متكامله ترتقي لمستوى
العالمي مبنيه على علم فعلا مبنيه على
معرفه فعلا قولوا ما يبقاش بس بيزنس او
حاجه بعمل منها فلوس بس تكون حاجه بجد
يمكن بتغير في حياه اطفال كثير في حاجات
بسيطه بس تكون بجد بيعمل فرق في حياه
الاولاد والاهالي اللي عندهم اطفال اللي
عندها احتياجات خاصه في مجتمع يعرف قليل
قوي عن يعني احتياجات الخاصه
[موسيقى]